a traveler comes upon the statue of an
emperor inscribed with the words my name
is Ozymandias King of Kings look upon my
works and despair only there's nothing
left beside it
except empty desert
it is good to be back I really wish
they'd let us play music up here why
because we'd already be on our feet
ready for action
considered your request for Passage
through our territory and we will not
stop you but do not expect us to save
you pursuing exploration always carries
risk I say we risk it everything
forbidden is sweet this is a good day it
is a good day
you do know where you're going right
nope oh boy
let's go make some history
I'd prepare anything just speak just
speak from your heart
we're about to enter unexplored space I
know you're all just as excited as I am
so let's give this everything we got and
May the force be with you
how was that perfect
we've served together
we've laughed together and we all owe
each other Our Lives you will surrender
or you will die
that's a very special thing we should
all get big bonuses this is history in
the making
years to a better future I will be sure
to bring my what does Lieutenant Malloy
call it my a game there you go buddy
find a way to preserve some kind of
Peace
humans have a tendency to reduce things
to black and white Good and Evil
[Music]
we can find a way to coexist you're a
kalon your people would like to see us
all dead
after all these years you're still able
to surprise me show the Galaxy that
humans are different that we value life
even when our enemies don't Captain you
are being deceived
[Music]
it's almost like yesterday was one life
and today's another
time
definitely worth the wait
[Music]